all right christian
christian where'd you grow up where are
you from virginia virginia virginia
right on the water virginia beach and
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents as a kid no single
parent home
just my mom
my dad was abusive to her and she didn't
want him doing that to us so as much as
it hurt her she divorced him
what kind of childhood did you have how
would you describe it uh
mixed up crazy
um exciting i i i've definitely came
from the other side of the tracks and
done a lot of crazy things been through
a lot of crazy [ __ ] for example
um well i was molested from the time i
don't know until i was six years old um
it was a game the guy said
who could be quiet my older brother
tried to play it and couldn't he
couldn't be quiet so i was the winner
and i felt proud of that um i thought it
was a game for a long time so that
continued oh yeah for several years that
was my first memory of in this world was
was that was that abuse um and that was
with a
father a 13 year old boy my mom's best
friend her son she would go over visit
best friend and we would you know i
would go upstairs and hang out with you
know the sun and you know we'd go to the
bathroom and uh
you know uh
i forget that i can't bring the word up
because
what's that called sodomy
um and
i only found out that something was
wrong with it because i was spending
that at a buddy's house who was my age
and his older brother was there talking
about some guy had gotten in trouble for
doing this that and the other to a kid
and i said oh wow i play that game too
all the time and he's like are you
kidding me i was like no i played that
all the time
he's like hold on a minute and he went
out of the room and i knew something was
wrong but i didn't really understand i'm
like six years old well his mom comes
back in and she's kind of tearing up and
she asks me what's going on and i told
her
and then my mom comes in to the house
because it was right down the street
and
i was six years old and i remember
the emotion that came from my mom was
just
awful it was terrible and this thing was
a game to me and all of a sudden like
this person who's so important to me my
mom is just completely upset and i i
felt that i felt everything that she
felt at six years old i felt everything
that she felt how horrible it was but i
didn't know what was going on she
explained it to me and you know the rest
of my family gets you know behind it and
i just
i never i never really thought about it
you know and i went to a counselor and
it didn't do any good because i didn't
really want to talk to the guy because i
didn't really know what you know i was
supposed to talk about and i just played
games you didn't even process it as
something wrong no no i mean i knew it
was something wrong but i didn't process
it in in any way shape or form i just
knew that something was wrong and
everybody was upset and that was it and
it wasn't my fault that's that's what i
took away from it there was no nobody
sat me down there was no you know
counseling sessions no fixing it up here
i just kind of filed it back in the
cabinet and you know moved on wow how
has it affected you
later in life
i'm sexually awkward i mean i
i don't know really how to describe that
it's just um i can't make the first move
with any woman uh
and it sucks it's embarrassing but you
know and i acknowledge it and you know
once we're in a relationship i tell them
about it and you know make sense then
but you know in the beginning i've lost
probably quite a few girlfriends from
not being able to to make that move
because i don't want to feel like i'm
pressuring somebody into something
whereas it didn't turn you into it
didn't make you gay or anything like
that no no no no no it didn't affect me
in that way um
i
i guess i have thoughts sometimes not
desires but wondering questioning
sometimes my sexuality but i know for a
fact you know that i'm not but it
definitely did did do that oh it's
interesting
so back to your childhood what what kind
of kid were you in high school uh very
smart um i actually one of the security
guards who was going to college on doing
psychology
did uh his uh like course study or
whatever his and thesis on me made me do
this really long test i scored like you
know somebody that had been in college
for eight years when i was in ninth
grade like i scored like off the charts
ridiculous and it turns out that a lot
of my anti-social behavior throughout my
years in school was because
like they would teach something on the
board and i got it boom let's move on
but then it was you know you got to go
over it again go over it again then you
got homework and you got reviewed and
you got a test and you got to go over it
it's like it's so slow that i'm just i'm
bored out of my mind and i'm i'm acting
out in all kinds of different ways
because i'm bored out of my mind and
they said you know let's put them in uh
special classes you know the higher up
education and i looked at all the kids
all the brainiacs and dorks getting
picked on and [ __ ] and i didn't want
that i don't wanna you know i don't
wanna be one of the smart kids i wanna
hang out with my friends and you know
take her out with everybody else so you
know when i took the test for that
placement test and you know elementary
school you know it was who's the he was
the first president chef boyardee you
know just stupid [ __ ] like that just to
fail it purposely um which i now regret
i wish i had you know taken the higher
road and and you know taking the bumps
and bruises because i think i'd be in a
completely different place in my life
but on the other hand
i've led such an extraordinary and
exciting life and i don't think i trade
it for anything i really don't you know
there's times that i that i wish i had
taken a different path but then i look
at you know all i've been through and
all i've experienced and the things i've
seen and i just i wouldn't trade it for
the world i really wouldn't even all the
bad [ __ ] you know that came along with
it you know being i mean you know
getting abused later in life
you know
it happened again yeah um and actually
this is really ironic um i got suspended
from school from high school
13 years old first year in ninth grade
and
my mom was upset and said you're not
gonna just sit at the house it's you
know a couple weeks before christmas
you're gonna go to social services and
volunteer and help wrap presents and
whatnot for you know unfortunate kids i
said okay you know whatever so i go
there and there's a guy there whose name
was mark and
he was a firefighter and i had always
wanted to be a firefighter and i had
never had a dad you know coming from a
single family home and you know he
took friend and you know we we became
friends and i thought you know this is
great you know this is awesome the
universe is finally you know giving me a
leg up this is a firefighter he can help
me get into firefighting you know he
doesn't have any kids he's always wanted
a son i don't have any i don't have a
dad i've always wanted a dad this is
perfect it's beautiful and you know
being brainwashed by how perfect the
situation was i didn't see any of the
red flags the hundreds of them that you
know were raised by him wanting me to
come and hang out at his house with him
alone away from my mom spend the night
you know he would rent movies that i
wanted to see that i couldn't watch you
know at my house bought me a pair of
rollerblades that my mom couldn't afford
me just you know lavish and all this
stuff which any normal person would see
as red flags but i didn't
and
uh i woke up one night and i just i felt
really sick and he's like he's like well
you know go go lay in my bed you know
you don't have to sleep on the couch go
lay in my bed and
i'll wake you up when i go to sleep i
was like all right cool so i did and i
woke up
with him
jerking me off basically
and
you know i'm 13 years old i'm little as
hell this is a grown-ass firefighter
grown man i don't want to just
you know say something and he freaks out
and tries to maybe kill me to hide this
or what i don't know you know i'm scared
shitless so i lay there and let it
happen and i kind of move a little bit
to like i'm gonna wake up and he you
know repels back and does his thing and
this goes on for a few minutes and
finally i you know i'm like oh man i
just can't sleep i just need to go smoke
a cigarette so i go out front smoke a
cigarette and of course run to the
neighbors and start banging on doors
until somebody let me in um a navy guy
did and i called the cops
turns out that he
went to one of the big churches and
where i grew up and was molesting
several other children and the church
kind of kept it unwrapped didn't say or
do anything about it which allowed it to
continue to happen
and
me coming forward and prosecuting him
the other victims came forward and
kind of stopped that whole that whole
training so as bad as it was i feel like
i was put in that position one because i
could handle it two
because it needed to stop and there
wasn't any other way of stopping it
that's great
so
good for you
as an adult you where's your life going
everywhere um i've had
almost every job under the sun
almost a licensed electrician i could i
could wire a house from the ground up
but i never got licensed i never did you
know you went through the paperwork or
any of that um
uh managed restaurants
uh cook surf
camp i love to travel i've traveled all
over the united states um i love to go
somewhere stay there for a while when i
get bored with it i'll either go back
home or
you know think of somewhere else i want
to go and i'll just go live there um
however just living kind of by the seat
of my pants where are you living today
uh skid row los angeles you're an intent
yes
yeah it's been there four and a half
years oh really yeah just came here for
maybe a few months and i'm just kind of
intrigued by the place that's how it
happens yeah it it and the funny thing
when i got here there was a guy leaving
to go to rehab and we got to talking and
he's like he's like dude just turn
around go home now he's like this place
will suck five ten years at you before
you know it and i was like i mean you
know i don't think that'll happen if it
did i guess i'd be all right with that
but it has it's it's it instantly sucks
five years out of me but you know i've
learned and seen
a lot like a lot there's a lot going on
in these streets that you know people
don't know about yeah but what's your
drug
heroin heroin yep
and there when you got introduced
introduced to win
uh a matter of fact i
this
uh thing went all the way back
uh wrestling with a buddy and it went
all the way back the back of my hand was
touching my head and when i went to the
doctor subsequently got tramadol which
is a
painkiller and if you take a bunch of
them you get really messed up and uh
that's where i got introduced to pills
yeah and addicted yeah yeah you get yeah
because once they once they stop giving
them to you you go through withdrawals
you don't know how's going on you feel
like crap for days and somebody you know
finally recognizes and says dude yeah
you're going through withdrawals you
just take another one you feel great and
i did and that was it i mean it's it's
feel like crap for a week or two or you
know keep taking it so you keep taking
it and pills are way too expensive so
one day you run into heroin which is way
cheaper right and so here we are how do
you support yourself now
i boost right now that's what i do um
yeah i boost yeah yeah never done it
before um until i got here i got here
and i met a girl and i said how do
people make money she said well there's
this way
sexual stuff i was like i'm not doing
that she said well you can boost or you
know
i was like that sounds good i can do
that and so that's what i do and i don't
do it in a conventional manner
how do you do it i walk in fill up a
basket with whatever
is net was is needed most sellable and
walk out the door either the front door
or the emergency exit
and i'm pretty fast so
i don't get caught you've been caught i
don't get caught i've been caught i mean
you know i'll run out and there'll be a
cop sitting there
um things like that you know where you
get caught because you know five years
of doing it almost every day you know
you're gonna you're gonna you know run
out and see a cop and what happens when
you get caught go to jail for how long a
day two days um if you have warrants
which i did and usually do because i
don't like going to court um
then you stay for longer and it
the first time i had to stay for four
days i went through withdrawals in jail
i ended up in my own cell upstairs away
from everybody else and i couldn't even
hear anybody with a red thing on my door
that said hostile inmate and i had a
doctor had to check on me every hour
because i was hallucinating i was naked
i was running around myself in the walls
and it was absolutely nuts i thought i
thought the people were in the jail were
having a party and you know laughing at
me and looking at me and i was the the
spectacle and the joke and i thought my
family was coming from virginia and when
they got here they were going to save me
and it just it was a whole nutty ordeal
and that's that's what i went through uh
with withdrawals and as soon as i got
out i still felt like absolute [ __ ] so
as soon as i got out
and felt great it's i akin it to popeye
taking the spinach when he takes it and
he just feels great that's that's how it
is yeah what do you think your chances
are of getting clean one day oh
excellent excellent this is this is
another point of my life and i'll look
back at this in 10 years and you know
laugh and and look at the lessons that i
learned from it because everything in my
life i've i've
done it's happened for a reason and i've
learned you know a lesson off of it and
like i say there's been a lot of bad
there's been a lot of good um i'd say
more good than bad but you know it's
it's all meant something to me and it's
you know wherever you go after this you
know heaven hell or death in the ground
whatever you believe in
wherever you go the only thing you can
possibly take with you is memories and
with that i mean i'm the richest person
you'll probably ever meet
you know and
so you know this is just this is just
the point i've gotten clean just to see
if it was possible and it sucked but i
did i was clean for almost a year and
then you know decided that i wasn't done
with it and when i feel i'm done with
something that's it i'll be done so i'll
quit you got clean from heroin for a
year yep how'd you do it i went it was
back when i was in virginia i decided
one day i was like you know i'm gonna
try this whole sober thing you know i've
never i haven't been sober my entire
life i started smoking pot when i was 12
and i've pot drinking alcohol to pills
my entire life i don't i can't remember
being sober since i was 12. i was like
let's let's give it a whirl let's see
who i am let's figure out how to go
called turkey or
no well yes actually i had to because
the place that i went to uh salvation
army you have that's that's they don't
have any drugs they don't give you any
anything to help you it is 100
you go there and you suck it up because
you go there you have to work 40 hours a
week so you have to get up at like 5 30
in the morning shower [ __ ] shower shave
go down for breakfast and then prayer
thing and then you go to work and when
you get off work they have activities
and groups and this that the other to
keep you busy keep you focused but the
whole time i'm feeling like crap like i
want to die i can't sleep at night i'm
kicking you know i don't sleep i have to
get up at work i just it was absolute
hell but the only thing that kept me in
there
was my mom i've had the most
the
closest awesome relationship with my mom
i love her dearly she's my best friend
and she said to me before i went she
said
because of this and all that we had gone
through with the heroin and you know the
drugs and she said uh you forever
damaged our relationship you've forever
damaged the special bond that we had
and those words you know reverberated in
my ear and that's the only thing that
kept me in there
i mean you've no idea the hell that i
went through like not sleeping for days
and having to work your ass off and
going to these groups and [ __ ] you feel
like crap you just wanna crawl in a hole
and die
and that's that's for weeks in that
relationship with your weeks and that
huh that relationship with your mom kind
of gave you the money that is the only
thing that kept me in there and i told
her that because when she said it to me
it broke my heart it literally broke my
i'm sure it broke her heart to say it
and you know i talked about it to her
about it later and i was like you know
you've never said anything like that to
me i was like and if you hadn't there's
no way i would have stayed in that place
there's no way i would have gotten clean
there's no way i would i would have left
the first day it was absolute hell i was
like the only thing that kept me in
there was your words and i wanted to fix
that
and
i did and unfortunately
she doesn't i've told her that i've
relapsed a few times but she doesn't
know that i'm basically a full-time user
again
so what what what is hair why do you
think you use heroin is there something
it levels me out to a point where i can
organize my thoughts and do
anything otherwise i'm completely manic
i mean i'm sure you can see from this
video i'm a little kind of everywhere
and all over the place without heroin
i'm
just a basket case i mean i akin my
brain to disneyland there's a lot of
noise a lot of things a lot of people
running around animals weird [ __ ] to
look at a lot of you know bangs and pops
and their heroine helps you with that
just brings me down kind of levels me
out and marijuana used to do that but i
quit swung a pot to actually become a
firefighter and when that didn't pan out
i went back to smoke a pot i smoked one
time and i felt like i was 13. it was
uncomfortable and you know weird and i
didn't like it so i didn't smoke pot and
i started drinking that's when i went
through my drinking phase and cocaine
and then when that ended with the pills
then the pills took over and like i say
from the age of 13 until now i've i've
pretty much been [ __ ] up every day
you know forever i kind of
you know wonder who i am sometimes
you know i mean not being sober for
years you kind of forget who you are you
know you're you're you're you're a
different person when you're high you
know all the time
you're a completely different person so
how do you think you've changed from
your years living like this
i mean
when i was 21 i was managing a
restaurant i was making beaucoup bucks i
mean this is 2000 i was i was making
almost a thousand a week take home which
it was a lot for me i mean in 2000 i was
20 years old it's a lot of money you
know and it just it went up from there i
was in the same restaurant for four
years um there was five the guy who had
five restaurants i could cook any of the
menus at all five restaurants i could do
anything and all the restaurants i would
go from restaurant restaurant when
things would happen the one 18th street
girl was my main place i ordered all the
food for there i did the schedules i
took care of the employees i made sure
everybody was there i worked from 11 a.m
till 2 8 2 3 a.m every day
and you know i was a hard worker you
know all i did was smoke pot and
you know i i really think that the pot
me and marijuana was a good combination
me and everything else no drinking i'm
irish i go way off hill i've been hit i
walked across the highway and get by a
car broke into a
uh van that the doubletree hotel used to
pick people from the airport i broke the
window out and i hopped in and took a
nap because i was too injured from
getting hit by a car on the highway to
make it all the way home woke up the
next morning bloody and bruised from
head to toe no shoe no pants leg over
here no wallet didn't know where my bike
was and went inside the hotel and dude's
like what the hell happened i was like i
don't know i woke up in the gutter dude
and called for a ride and you know went
home and you know pieced the piece of
the day together i had blacked out at a
christmas party and rode my bike home
got hit by a car on the highway and left
my bike there told her dude was cool it
was cool man go home and watch couldn't
make it home because i was too injured
so i broke the window out of the van
hopped in took a nap
wow and that's just one of many
ridiculously crazy drunk stories where
any normal person would stop drinking
but no i didn't so the heroine has kind
of replaced the alcohol yes yes one
thing is replaced you know marijuana
replaced by alcohol and cocaine and
alcohol cocaine now pills and heroin now
we're heroin
and now we're kind of getting into chris
oh is that right yeah stay away from the
fentanyl no that is one decision uh that
i've managed to make in the in the
positive column is i've never touched
fentanyl animal
so
i'm not a you know let's see how high i
can get
i just
you know at this point it's maintenance
i have to do the heroin i'm not ready to
go through the withdrawals so
i'm kind of in a you know
jump from foot to foot you know
junky limbo i guess yeah what's your
biggest regret
not
having
used
the potential i know is within me
and i don't know if maybe it's coming i
don't know i'm kind of like waiting for
that dare to be great situation i don't
know if like i'm supposed to wait for it
i'm looking for it my eyes are open like
i'm looking for the exit but i haven't
seen it yet and i'm
literally looking for it and have been
for years how old are you
41 45 yeah um i i like to write i love
to write people that have written read
my writing love it and say dude you need
to be a writer um i can argue my ass off
people say you should be a lawyer you
know there's a few things that i put my
hands to and people say you know you
should definitely do that but i can't
put my heart and soul into anything
until i know that's what i'm supposed to
do
because like literally i dive in 100 and
i don't want to put my heart and soul in
10 years into something if it's not what
i'm supposed to be doing
so then i kind of do nothing and that
that's my regret is that not knowing
what to do i do nothing
and i don't really know what to do about
that do something
what just do it but what it doesn't
matter
but i got i when you see me do something
i'm 100 about it and i can't like i
don't know what to choose if you do
anything and apply yourself you'll fall
in love and you'll
but i want to make sure i'm doing what
i'm supposed to do i really believe that
that we're put here there's people that
are supposed to be homeless like okay if
everybody were exactly the same how
boring would this world be it would
literally suck there would be nothing i
mean there would be no no contrast you
know you can't have dark without light
good without evil so i believe that
people some people have to be homeless
it sucks but some people have to be
homeless i don't think i was meant to be
homeless this is just a point in my life
but some people have to be this some
people have to be obese some people have
to you know clean up [ __ ] and you know i
don't know what i'm supposed to be and
that's what pisses me off and i can't
figure it out and i don't want to put my
heart and soul into anything until i
know that's what i'm supposed to do and
i can't waste 10 years trying to be a
lawyer to figure out you know i'm
supposed to be a writer or a stand-up
comedian or you know blood don't i don't
know
you know and so before i do nothing yeah
i've wasted 40 years trying to figure
out what to do and
yeah it's that's that's my regret that's
that's where i'm at yeah it'd be
frustrating yeah it's very frustrating
because i know that i have the potential
to do
you know
good you know for myself i know i have a
lot of potential inside of me and i just
don't know what to do with it i have no
idea what to do with it you've been in
love before huh you've been in love oh
yeah oh yeah oh god that rocky freaking
road
better to have loved and never loved and
lost and never loved it all
i kind of questioned that sometimes
i wonder about that one yeah it's damn
close whichever way you go sexy the way
uh oh well yeah hell yeah well you see
ignorance is bliss and literally
ignorance is freaking bliss man if i
could
now i say that but i don't mean it if i
can go back to being as you know stupid
to the way the world is and things like
that that it would be great but you know
i'm not and it sucks and you know having
loved and then lost like that hurts so
bad like what would it be if you just
never loved you know you wouldn't know
what you were missing it's like having a
cell phone you don't know how cool a
cell phone have a cell phone is to get
one you know before that you live fine
without a cell phone but then you get
one it's great yeah that's advice about
taking those chances risks
true but is it
you know better to be ignorant
tonight to not to go through all that
[ __ ] to just kind of just be happy you
know being a you know
just a nine to five
[ __ ] you know a a wheel in the cop you
can make an argument for either one
there you go exactly so it's you know
like i said i i would not trade my life
or it's experiences for anything in the
world but i do
wish that i had my hands to put into
something
functional or positive or productive i
think it's just a matter of
figuring it out exactly that's i it's a
matter of what i figured i mean whether
it's a lawyer or an architect or a
writer or whatever it's just you just do
it they'll don't do all of them no you
just do one of them well actually you
can do all of them people do all of them
people do many things there people
there's lawyers that i mean there's
house moms gonna be lawyers when they're
45 years old so yeah
but but hanging out on a skid row for
another five years is not not gonna no
no no no no no no if i if i'm here in
another five years
shoot me
shoot me not with the camera with a gun
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
treat people with kindness
i mean if we could get that right this
world would be such
a different i mean war would be gone
all of this none of this would exist
none of this would exist if people
people
say i'm gonna look out for me i'm gonna
look out for number one so you got one
person looking out for you
but if you looked out for everybody that
you saw on a daily basis and tried to
help them out if they needed it in any
way that you could and everybody did the
same thing then instead of you looking
out for you one person you got everybody
you meet on a daily basis looking out
for your best benefit and all you have
to do is do the same and instead of one
person looking out for you you you got
everybody looking out for you and i mean
that that's just a functional world you
know there's no people that are i mean
it amazes me that people die on our
planet from a lack of food that is
psychotic you know it takes three days
to die from hunger from like not eating
and it's a horrible death from what i
hear and it happens like every eight
seconds on this planet and that's insane
that where people are dying from the
lack of food and then we're throwing
away 50 000 tons of it every day
i mean just see this is the manic part i
just started jumping from one thing to
the next but yeah i mean if people could
be kind to each other and just treat
people literally like you would like to
be treated you know with respect you
know you know you shouldn't have to earn
respect and love and kindness i
here it took
a year before people stopped punching me
in the face when i walked by and
throwing [ __ ] at me
until they got to know me you know it
shouldn't be like that you should just
take me for face value and if i'm an
[ __ ] then you treat me like an
[ __ ] down the road not immediately
and i have to prove myself
all right christian thank you so much
for sharing your story yep
sorry very interesting thank you we wish
you best of luck getting out of here
thank you
all right thank you